ce qui nécessite comme égal une première
fois que les gentils ça je peux sans
croit toujours acteur c'est peu mais
rifi comme sa selected rêve c'était pour
ça que j'étais un acteur d'ailleurs
quand ils sont acteurs et quand on est
acteur maintenant à 118
ça veut dire qu'ils avaient une chance
sur 10 pour qu'on travaille pas oui on
peut évaluer environ à 80 % toujours
mais en moralisant que ce sont des
intermittents
on n'a pas l'impression comme un autre
travailleur d'être au chômage et un
travailleur qui n'a pas d'emploi il est
au chômage il écrit délai pour trouver
un emploi
et quand ils assurent une pointe ça y
est il là il travaille un acteur il est
toujours ni au chômage ni au travail il
a toujours des projets même quand ils
travaillent pas et quand il travaille ça
peut être sur une journée sur deux jours
et après c'est fini pour passer à
oublier faut faire des choses il faut
jouer alors on joue à tout prix pour
s'exprimer pour travailler et pour que
les gens ne vous oublie pas résultat on
accepte de travailler dans des
entreprises où on a absolument aucune
couverture sociale et on se retrouve
confronté à des problèmes mène pas de
salaire mais quelquefois tout simple
respect humain
comment est ce que les gens peuvent
avoir envie de vous employez si je
connaisse pas le trombinoscope commande
alors il faudrait que ces fichiers
existent et déjà une tentative de claude
wolff qui est qui et bien ça moyen passé
il faudrait que tous les comédiens
qu'ils soient chez claude et que ce soit
une seule chose qui existe comme ça et
qui sert de référence à tous les
employeurs potentiels et il faut donner
envie aux gens de travailler ensemble
c'est pas facile
vous n'êtes plus cfa pour les fichiers
du pour les agents les imprésarios où ça
n'a aucun rapport
quelques affiches y est très bien fait
doit remplacer la profession
d'imprésario qui deviendra un
secrétariat de jean propre occupée oui
je pense ça serait bien
ça serait bien mais les agents je sais
pas si ça trouve du travail
ce suis pas sûr en tout cas ça discute
d'argent ce qui est les acteurs savent
pas discuter argent
[Musique]